well thank you very much for the fine
introduction uh I'm very happy to be at
Hillsdale again it's a wonderful place
and I hope I'll come back even
again I'm going to speak tonight on a
very old case called the nenko case uh
we have to go back six decades which is
a long time even for me to go
back um but
it was a case that defined the
CIA
perhaps paralyzed it and some people
think destroyed the old
CIA for better or worse so it's the most
important case of the Cold War now I
hope you don't mind a little time
travel because this I'm going to take
you back and forth in time but only
twice or three times first we're going
to go back to
November 22nd
1963 63 excuse me uh we all know John F
Kennedy was shot in
Dallas we also know that the alleged
assassin Lee Harvey
Oswald uh was shot the next day in a
prison Dallas Police Station actually
and you know and we know there was a
Waring commission
investigation uh so we're pretty
familiar with that but what no one knew
at the time and knew for another 15
years was that there was a crisis
developing at the
CIA immediately after the
assassination not everyone in the CIA
but one school of
thought in the uh counter intelligence
staff the research run by a guy called
Raymond
Rocka they began developing a
theory that the Soviet Union and its
leader Nikita
kushev was behind the
assassination that kusf killed Kennedy
to say it shortly uh the theory was
based on information that no one else
knew and uh so I don't get you too
excited the theory didn't prove out but
for one
thing they knew from uh their
intelligence work that
Oswald had gone to Russia spent two and
a half years there and their sources
which don't mean they not necessarily
accurate but their sources told them
that the KGB had been preparing oswal as
a um Sleeper Agent secondly they knew
that oswal had gone to the Soviet
Embassy uh on October 1st which is
roughly 6 weeks before the
assassination but even more uh
intriguing osor had written a letter in
those days letters were intercepted by a
mail cover to embassies he wrote a
letter to the Soviet Embassy in
Washington talking about um this is five
weeks before the assassination talking
about a plan
and his meeting with a man called cave
in the Russian Embassy or the CIA knew
that he was probably referring to
castino probably his name was COV I got
that wrong
kov who was um the head of their
assassination uh Bureau called the
department of the 13th they also knew uh
that he had seen in the Russian Embassy
they had intercepted car respondence NSA
which was able to decode uh typing going
back and forth on cables that a man
called
ol
NE penko EXC
penko I later saw this man by the way in
Moscow but that he had written an
assessment of our world that went back
to the
KGB now this was
a this was not the general opinion or
even opinion of the FBI or anyone it was
a faction in the CIA but the CIA
director or the person in charge of
their covered operations Richard Helms
who later became the director of the CIA
Richard Holmes roed he had a crisis on
his hands or more better said a dilemma
on one hand he could report this
information to the Warren Commission
which then would have to deal with um a
possible Soviet assassination of an
American president and Helms um as he
told me later on was concerned because
the year before
1962 uh the Cuban Missile Crisis we came
very close to a nuclear war with Russia
so the last thing Helms wanted to
do was set the stage for a nuclear
confrontation on the other hand and if
he kept uh the this information
secret CIA was a very vicious Place back
in the 60s and the 70s and maybe even
today he knew that someone would leak it
and he'd be accused of suppressing
information that could lead to the
uncovering of a plot that killed the
president so just as he was tormented by
this we're now January
1964 just after new years's suddenly a
Defector comes from Russia the defect's
name as I mentioned earlier was yurin
nenko yurin nenko came with a
message the message
was I was Lee har oswal's case officer
during his two and a half years in
Russia moreover after the
assassination the KGB had me do a
complete investigation of all of
Oswald's relations with all of the
intelligence Services of Soviet
Union and I'm now here to tell you the
facts and the truth of the matter and
the fact and the truth is that Soviet
intelligence had nothing whatsoever to
do with Oswell they never recruited him
they never trained him well this came as
a great relief to Helms because now he
went to Earl Warren who is the Warren
Commission was named after chief justice
Warren and he said look we have a
Defector who tells
us that Russia had nothing to do he's a
uh you know close had great amounts of
information from the KGB and he just
came over and we now know we can now
dismiss the idea of Russia
involvement and Warren said well that's
good we'll have him
testify and Helm said well wait a moment
we haven't checked this man's Bona fites
now in the CIA if a man's Bona fites
aren't approved it means they don't know
whether he's still a Russian agent or a
dangle who's been sent over to deliver
disinformation or is legitimate so
Warren was confused by that he said you
haven't decided that he said no that
will take months and so it's better you
don't bring him before the warrant
commission okay so he never appeared
before the Warren Commission he never
appeared anywhere he was essentially
deep sixed and he this was a secret no
one heard his name no one knew about his
role in anything for at
least uh over a decade up up until let's
say 1978 or 77 so all this time it was
The Greatest Secret the CIA held that
they had uh received this Defector who
had cleared Russia from being involved
in the Kennedy
assassination why it came out in 1978
January 1978 is I published a book
called Legend which revealed the entire
case now you might ask how did I ever
become
involved with Yuri nenko and how did I
ever find out about the case and I'm
going to tell you
you which we now have to travel time
again to
1976 I was a
reporter writer at the New
Yorker and The New Yorker had one rule
it had a lot of rules one rule this
relevant you can't do anything for the
Readers
Digest no no I
mean you know you were fired basically I
was on a New Yorker St and the editor of
the Readers Digest a wonderful man
called Edward
Thompson uh called me and said we would
like you to do a book for us on the
Kennedy
assassination I said I can't do that
uh New York would never allow it he said
well I have something to tell you if you
agree to do this book we will provide
you with the man who was oswal's case
officer in the KGB in Russia now I had
never even heard there was such a man or
that that he had a case off and he'll
tell you the entire story of the Russian
involvement well this was something I
couldn't turn down no matter what New
Yorker said so I
agreed and um they
delivered I should say the CIA
delivered and the sinko to me but they
had what had happened was the CIA after
a Defector is useless to them which
happens pretty quick the next stage is
exploiting them uh for public for uh
public relations or propaganda however
you want to term it so was someone like
pankovski they write the pankovski
papers Peter Debian wrote the D
pankovski papers and and they put it out
under the person's name and here they
wanted to put out the nenko story The
Readers Digest was a natural platform
because it had the kind of audience they
wanted I had nothing to do with it by
the way this all before I was ever
contacted but the's doest had a huge
internal fight about whether the
Washington Bureau would do this or a
headquarters and Pleasantville would do
this and as a compromise they deci had
to get a toal Outsider so I Ed this as a
total Outsider I knew nothing whatsoever
about spies or Espionage or double
agents dangles all the terms I was going
to come to learn deception all that and
they just wanted I knew something about
the Kennedy assassination they just
wanted someone who was unconnected to
the digest to write this book and the
CIA
delivered uh
theko literally CIA officer called Jamie
j
Jon um who was part of their division of
public
exploitation and was now running the
senko actually you know guy on crutches
walks in to the office the digest office
in Washington with nenko and he said
he's all yours
so I thought this was a huge scoop and I
those days I was looking for
Scoops
so uh you know I began a series of
interviews with him and you can read all
about that if you want him my book
assumed nothing or if you prefer I wrote
a more lengthly book called deception on
on this matter any case
when no matter what I and I knew a good
deal about the assassination because I
had interviewed and was the only person
to interview all the members of the
Warren Commission and our staff their
lawyers and investigators and I had all
the documents so I was pretty conversent
on that subject and he seemed to know
nothing really about osor all he could
say is we had nothing to do with them
and so I didn't know what to do so I
went to the Soviet Embassy in Washington
and I thought well maybe I can go to
Russia and check on some of the people
he's named who knew osw world and a
Russian uh
Council May political officer which is
the head of the KGB probably named
called Igor auu meets with me and I say
I'd like to go to Russia for this
purpose he said well first of all you
don't have to go to Russia because you
happen to have right here in
Washington the best source on oor that
we have I said who's that he said Ur in
senko now I found it you know why would
the UR in was supposed to be a traitor
he had defected from Russia why would
Russia
be vouching for his bonafides when even
the CIA
would and so I went back to the Jamie
Jameson he said no
no the guy just didn't know what he was
saying uh everyone in the CIA agrees
this guy is as good as gold okay but I
had read a newspaper story in the New
York Times um about a guy being fired
from the CIA called James Jesus
Angleton uh who was the head of their
Counter Intelligence staff and he was
fired for I don't know running a mail
cover program or something fired on
Christmas day uh
uh five I think and so I thought well
very controversial he's no longer in the
CIA I'll call him I asked James in for
his number he said this guyy is so
secretive his wife doesn't thinks he
works for the post office he would never
find we we can never give you his number
so I looked in the phone
book I mean you know the phone book is
the greatest asset a journalist
has